**Susan Daniels**: Everyone welcome to day three I am so excited that you are with us and we're hitting that halfway point in our five day boot camp.
**Susan Daniels**: So listen to your feedback yesterday really appreciate the arm the shout outs that you gave to the mentoring team they totally rock and I want to thank you for the compliments, those of you that we gave words of encouragement.
**Susan Daniels**: much appreciated, so I do want to.
**Susan Daniels**: be responsive to the feedback.
**Susan Daniels**: And this is what I like to say is um.
**Susan Daniels**: oftentimes I would stop and be distracted by the chat and looking for questions that may arise, so what i'm going to do is i'm going to uncover some content and then i'll let you know that I am pausing for questions.
**Susan Daniels**: and only then, when i'm really going to be looking to select to scan chat for questions, but with That being said.
**Susan Daniels**: um I really want to reinforce our group norms our ground rules that we had regarding the chat.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm just going to bring this slide back up to you, which is please use the chat during lectures solely to make comments on that we are responsive to me calling out for responses, or if I asked for examples of things.
**Susan Daniels**: let's keep the chat during lecture time.
**Susan Daniels**: focus solely on the curriculum okay that'll slow the role of the chat and it allow people to actually see other people's answers, and if you have a question that is relevant to the topic.
**Susan Daniels**: And you didn't get it answered that's what the Q amp a can be used for we have mentors online and they can try to answer some of the curriculum related questions that didn't get answered by me in real time.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so that's where the Q amp a can be used the q&a can also be used if you have technical issues let's not put your technical issues in the chat.
**Susan Daniels**: Those are personal problems, so to speak, take those for one on one communication with mentors they're standing by to provide you information on how to access materials Those sort of things.
**Susan Daniels**: So with those ground rules reinforced okay um we should be able to keep the chat to you know just up a real time dynamic discussion about the topics on hand.
**Susan Daniels**: The second thing that I want to do is, I want to confirm that I will make sure I do the mastery questions at the end got a little feedback on that and I will, yes, Sir, yes ma'am I will be sure to incorporate all the mastery questions.
**Susan Daniels**: With that said let's take a look at where we're going today.
**Susan Daniels**: Yesterday we went deep on only four topics today we're finishing up talk some basics, that we need to have in place before we get into that execution phase Okay, we are still in the.
**Susan Daniels**: Planning Okay, laying the groundwork getting everything integrated and aligned Okay, we are still in the process of ready set Okay, we are not on go yet.
**Susan Daniels**: So those, these are the topics will be covering.
**Susan Daniels**: My goal for today is to have two breaks during the morning session typically about one hour apart, so our next break will be at the top of the hour coming up and it'll be.
**Susan Daniels**: A 15 minute break and then the next one will be at a quarter after that the following our will end up today at Eastern time it'll be 130 Eastern time it'll be a one hour break for lunch.
**Susan Daniels**: With that said let's start rockin and rollin let's go.
**Susan Daniels**: we're going to start with integrate project planning activity, so we have been building let's kind of.
**Susan Daniels**: get our heads back in the game take a little walk down memory lane, so we have done a lot to get our team together to assess the skill sets that we have look at what training means maybe in required set up some mentoring pairing coaching bringing people up to speed letting people.
**Susan Daniels**: organize the work, to the extent they can we've kind of set those norms in place, and now we moved into.
**Susan Daniels**: Getting the work done so we had to start with well where the projects come from they come from business cases that your leadership went out and advocated money for.
**Susan Daniels**: Then they bring you into the game and that starts the Charter and the Charter is still very visionary it's still very abstract.
**Susan Daniels**: But it helps you get on this same.
**Susan Daniels**: visual image, the same mindset with your sponsors.
**Susan Daniels**: Remember sponsors are the people who are who have the money, who have this spending power if you want to try to remember it that way sponsors have spending power.
**Susan Daniels**: Then, once we kind of had a common understanding through the Charter when we set about trying to really figure out how we're going to do this, and this is when we begin to develop our scope.
**Susan Daniels**: And, yesterday we covered a lot of components that go into our scope we've got to have a high level scope statement we have to collect all of the requirements and looked at slides said there's lots of different kinds of requirements okay.
**Susan Daniels**: And then there's we looked at specific kinds of requirements for our product so there's two slides all the kinds of requirements and then this slide on the types of product requirements really important slides.
**Susan Daniels**: Then, once we had all our requirements we couldn't just have them unorganized we had to put them in something called a work breakdown structure.
**Susan Daniels**: And we saw a video on what one looked like and we looked at ways that we are they can be used and from the work breakdown structure we had our core foundational document.
**Susan Daniels**: With those work breakdown dictionaries to help us move to the next step, which is schedule management I schedule management plan the schedule management plan used our work breakdown structure.
**Susan Daniels**: All of those work packages and then.
**Susan Daniels**: We have the ability to decompose important vocabulary word decompose the work even further into activities, the pmi terms, our work packages and activities and.
**Susan Daniels**: Once we had our schedule of all the activities we can lay the workout over time.
**Susan Daniels**: And we put that into various schedule examples okay there's all coming back to you, you know coffee kicking in right okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So we've got our scope we've got our schedule, now that we have an idea of how much how we're going to do this we start to put our budget together.
**Susan Daniels**: We looked at how we built the budget, all the way from the activities, up to the master budget, including contingencies for.
**Susan Daniels**: certain activities contingencies for the whole project contingency funds for the whole project, as well as yes those not often disclosed.
**Susan Daniels**: Management reserves Okay, I saw someone put in chatting a couple of people actually saying my company doesn't use management reserves.
**Susan Daniels**: Maybe it does, maybe it doesn't it doesn't always share most of the time management reserves are held at the C suite level okay that's where the reserves are held.
**Susan Daniels**: So you may or may not ever be informed of these management reserves it's only when you're in deep trouble that you have the opportunity to to find out about them.
**Susan Daniels**: So we got our scope I scheduled our budget and the other axiom that we are evaluated on our reputations are determined by our the ability to get quality looked at the different tools and techniques to monitor and control quality.
**Susan Daniels**: So now it makes sense that today we start talking about integration because we've got a lot of plans here and we need to start to integrate them.
**Susan Daniels**: Now, this is a slide this rich with content so i'm going to pause and give you a moment to consume this lie.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so.
**Susan Daniels**: This is several different ways of saying that as a project manager it's your job, your job, this is not really a delegated job.
**Susan Daniels**: You can build up a small Council out around you have subject matter experts.
**Susan Daniels**: That can aid you and guide you but it's ultimately your role to integrate all of these plans Okay, and that includes the procurement plan and communication plan, the risk management plan our stakeholder.
**Susan Daniels**: Engagement plan there's more to come Okay, but your role is to kind of gap, assess and update and integrate making sure that the left hand and the right hand and it all fits together and understanding that a change in one place is going to have a ripple effect in others.
**Susan Daniels**: Did I fly past the enablers that's a good question there no.
**Susan Daniels**: You know that's a good catch here is a task, without having the enabler slide.
**Susan Daniels**: I owe you an enabler slide I will make a note of that and try to get it to you before the close of the boot camp okay.
**Susan Daniels**: All right, so how do we get test questions on this right, this is a whole slide that's got a lot of information on it, so it means can be a source for test questions um so.
**Susan Daniels**: here's what.
**Susan Daniels**: Let me restart that i'm a professor, as well as a trainer for p&p exam prep courses and other project management courses I write test questions for a living, if you will, and if I was given this slide.
**Susan Daniels**: What I would do is use a scenario, and I will be describing a situation in which our Mr Mrs so and so Okay, is trying to do, identify and correct gaps.
**Susan Daniels**: and identify conflicts in her her project management plan or his project management plan, what is this project manager doing or what processes is project manager doing.
**Susan Daniels**: I might use another paragraph from this and build it into a scenario and be able to ask the students to recognize that what the project manager is doing, are responsible for is the integration on management.
**Susan Daniels**: So I would encourage you to be able to tie these activities or the benefits or the outcomes that are trying to be achieved through integration management with that that nomenclature.
**Susan Daniels**: The big the big takeaway here is that you are building a master plan and because you're the project leader and the project manager it's up to you to make sure that it all fits together okay.
**Susan Daniels**: You plan the work, then you work, the plan.
**Susan Daniels**: So you have the the master project management plan now it's really about how it all fits together is that three ring binder Okay, the project implementation plan and the project management plan hey they are.
**Susan Daniels**: The project implementation plan has to do with scope it really has to do with how you are going to.
**Susan Daniels**: implement the manifestation of all of this scope okay and it's going to be all of your requirements and it's going to be all of the details.
**Susan Daniels**: Your project management plan is the one that takes the whole thing in I just I reviewed last night and I realized there's two different ones, and I wanted to clarify the two.
**Susan Daniels**: um so what I want to do is to say the project management plan is the master document the implementation plan is really about all the components.
**Susan Daniels**: of how you're going to execute getting your your scope done it's not the plan of how you're going to build your scope that's your scope management plan how i'm going to build it and where i'm going to store it, but the implementation plan is how you're actually gonna.
**Susan Daniels**: You know what solution you're going to have what resources are going to be required to try to do that implementation.
**Susan Daniels**: But I digress, allow me to say that.
**Susan Daniels**: Your project management plan is going to be not all in one place okay it's not all going to be on one platform not quite yet okay we've gotten much better in our industry to be able to have one platform that can House all the components that we need for communications for.
**Susan Daniels**: calculation for storing for.
**Susan Daniels**: that's where it's got the outlook let's take teams, for example.
**Susan Daniels**: he's got communication capabilities gotten an email and zoom and chat it's got the communication features it's got a way to have all of your contacts, for your stakeholder management it's got file management for storage and access.
**Susan Daniels**: But you're going to need more tools than just your desktop capabilities, you may need to have proficiency in.
**Susan Daniels**: engaging with accounts payable and being able to submit invoices appropriately in your organization invoices are going to come in from your vendors.
**Susan Daniels**: And you're going to have that have to ensure they get signed off on right and some sort of special document almost always has to go on top of whatever the vendor sends you you've got to be proficient in that, and probably facilitate getting it approved if you don't have the authority.
**Susan Daniels**: So your accounts payable team your payroll if you've got external staff temp staff that you have hired for your project because that talent is not available in house, well then you've got to be proficient in that system as well.
**Susan Daniels**: So really it's all about whatever tool or technology you use to manage your project to your desktop capabilities IT systems within your organization.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay it's anything you use to gather produce or disseminate information that can be your your filing drawer Okay, is part of your information management system.
**Susan Daniels**: So just.
**Susan Daniels**: For the exam you need to understand what the acronym stands for i've kind of costumes you before and i'm going to caution you again when you see an acronym in on a.
**Susan Daniels**: On the PM I curriculum it's fair game to just be an acronym on the test so we've covered a couple like the wps.
**Susan Daniels**: The resource assignment matrix and array am in a type of a Ram resource assignment matrix is that racy we cover what the are in a the sea and the I stands for, we are now talking about a on your pmi is right, you need to be able to.
**Susan Daniels**: recognize what that acronym stands for, if it's one of the answers you need to be able to roll it in and roll it out Okay, as one of the possible correct answers.
Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So we're still talking about integration right and the way we integrate is first we got our realizes we've got to integrate all of our technology and systems, we need to access right, we need to have certain skill sets and.
**Susan Daniels**: My mapping is one of them it's a rising skill okay to be able to do a mind map just saying it's not required in the industry quite yet.
**Susan Daniels**: To be proficient in mind mapping but it's rising as an in popularity and you may engage a stakeholder who expects to see communications in that medium so um knowing what technology, you need to be efficient, is all part of being a having an effective PM is.
**Susan Daniels**: So let's take a look at.
**Susan Daniels**: Integration classic integration.
and
**Susan Daniels**: that's interesting my slides are in a different order Okay, so your project, this seems to be we're going back to our project management plan components okay.
**Susan Daniels**: This is a very rich slide so I really am going to pause for a few seconds for you to to read it.
**Susan Daniels**: There was some feedback that the slides on have been a little blurry we have checked the resolution of our monitor and said, the highest resolution.
**Susan Daniels**: I am using presentation mode in my delivery, so we did some background check and we have it set as high resolution for broadcasting, I would encourage you guys.
**Susan Daniels**: To maybe on urine look at what device you're looking at and see if he leads me to move to a different screen to help you have greater look read resolution and legibility, but we are broadcasting at the highest resolution, we can okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So let's talk about the components of the project management plan.
**Susan Daniels**: you've heard me over and over talk about the subsidiary plans scope schedule cost quality resources okay.
**Susan Daniels**: But then down here i'm going to read to you because it's white on purple okay so i'm going to read to you some of the additional components that are included.
**Susan Daniels**: you're going to need to be aware of some of your project processes I alluded to that earlier, which is your accounts payable your payroll system you're working with HR to get external staff okay.
**Susan Daniels**: There may be on your project approach that's really part of saying i'm going to use this sort of life cycle of this sort of methodology, whether it's the.
**Susan Daniels**: predictive or adaptive then i'm going to use this kind of life cycle okay so that's going to be part of your project management plan.
**Susan Daniels**: The bomb the next one says change management plan now we haven't talked about that, but it is part of this morning's conversation so we're going to go deep on to the arm change management plan, what does it entail when is it used.
**Susan Daniels**: Some examples Okay, they want to talk about our configuration, or they are configuration management system.
**Susan Daniels**: Our management plan overall Okay, and our management reviews okay our management reviews is when are we going to have to go before governance.
**Susan Daniels**: And what is that cadence right and who sits on that governance Council right who's who is part of our governance, who has a voice, who has a vote, so to speak, okay so Those are some of the additional things that will you will need to build into our master plan.
**Susan Daniels**: So that we can have a robust project management plan now this This begs the question almost always from my students that's a lot of work to build all of that.
**Susan Daniels**: My leadership wants me to ready, you know fire aim right they want me out the door and going like immediately they can't wait for me to build all these things and write all these things.
**Susan Daniels**: I dare say to you.
**Susan Daniels**: That, if you don't plan your work okay well i'll go back to the expression from arm.
**Susan Daniels**: I think it was Carnegie if you don't if you don't plan, if you fail to plan right, then you plan to fail.
**Susan Daniels**: So, remember, we keep saying over and over yesterday.
**Susan Daniels**: We write these these memos these in scope management plan schedule management plan and they're like letters to your sponsors and saying this is my approach, this is the way i'm going to do this, this is the way i'm going to go about and do that.
**Susan Daniels**: You are working on the project, you are making progress on the project and what you're doing by doing these individual plans you know these management plans.
**Susan Daniels**: You are showing leadership i've got an approach here's what i'm going to do you approve or do you have advice and guidance oftentimes we have got we have leadership that have project managers and go off half cocked okay or half you know half informed okay.
**Susan Daniels**: The hallmark of a professional project manager, is it, they do take the time to write these plans and they do follow the guidance in our our books right of what is entailed in each one of these plans they don't have to be long letters they don't have to be well.
**Susan Daniels**: they're not 3456 pages long they're only a couple pages at the most.
**Susan Daniels**: In the beginning this says hey here's the people i'm going to engage with these are the tools i'm going to use this is where i'm going to store here's the links to it.
**Susan Daniels**: Any advice and recommendations right and you send it up, and you can probably create two or three of these in a day right it's not hard to get your first draft of your plan out upstairs.
**Susan Daniels**: so that you can immediately get feedback coaching and guidance, so that you can keep moving so.
**Susan Daniels**: I daresay, even though this looks like on the screen a whole lot of work and writing it's really the hallmark of a professional project manager they use the tools that they've been trained to use OK.
**Susan Daniels**: I see a question that came across it says what is the distinction between additional components and subsidiary plans, these are our.
**Susan Daniels**: Knowledge areas that kind of came over from the pen box sixth edition, where we have robust processes associated with each one of these.
**Susan Daniels**: And how to write the plan and how to execute against it okay So these are robustly developed in the pen box sixth edition where your additional components are generally just a document a subsidiary document or documentation of a process okay it's not an entire.
**Susan Daniels**: Division or standard on knowledge area of of your project.
**Susan Daniels**: I hope that's helpful, these are your subsidiary plans are much more robust okay with they have.
**Susan Daniels**: outputs they have specific components that are part of it Okay, where your additional documents it's one and done once you create it you're done with it, where these have multiple subsidiaries have multiple sections and multiple elements involved in it, I hope, that's helpful.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay um your baselines important word important phrase your scope baseline schedule on baseline and cost baseline these are often referred to as the iron triangle, why iron.
**Susan Daniels**: iron triangle, because it's inflexible okay it's not Willy nilly doesn't get readily adjusted like something in your configuration system.
**Susan Daniels**: Once you build in and get approved your scope from all of your requirements approved your schedule and your cost your reputation is held executing to those baselines.
**Susan Daniels**: And only through formal change control can you make adjustments to it.
**Susan Daniels**: The upside of that is it protects you from trying to get people trying to do scope creep on you trying to navigate your project, and you know to be a little more beneficial for them right, you know, like Ben the purpose of the project.
**Susan Daniels**: to their way of doing it, the influencing and decision making is done we've locked in the scope schedule and cost okay.
**Susan Daniels**: It also protects your budget, you simply say that's not in my budget, and if you need this done, we need to go through formal change control to get the additional resources do you have additional resources.
**Susan Daniels**: I know well, at this point, I still need to stay, true to my arm my plan you know what i've been authorized to do, but I can send you the change change request form, if you want to pursue it most of the time if they don't have any additional money that's kind of the end of the discussion.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: All baselines as subsidiary um no not all baselines assists literary you don't have a baseline in your communication plan you are adapt and change your communication plan.
**Susan Daniels**: On the fly as on your stakeholders tell you what you need to Okay, or as events change in your arm and evolve in your project your risk management plan evolves over time okay your procurement plan may need to evolve right.
**Susan Daniels**: Your stakeholders are constantly coming in and out of your projects and know these are not locked in just your scope scheduling cost thing.
**Susan Daniels**: I need to move on.
**Susan Daniels**: I don't think there's a lot to expand upon on this line is simply how would you go about building your project management plan and it's the usual culprits as far as enablers okay.
**Susan Daniels**: On expert judgment again comes out at the top, go to the people in the know go to the people closest to the work that needs to be done right get the right people in the room okay.
**Susan Daniels**: And that's where your sponsors oftentimes can guide you okay that's where you go and indicate who you think you're going to invite to do these things.
**Susan Daniels**: Right and that's where they give you the feedback and go no use this expert versus that expert that guy's really prickly or don't use this Gal she's doesn't really support the project.
**Susan Daniels**: So go use this person in that division, they understand what we're trying to do and they're supportive Thank you good to know again super valuable to send your plans up to senior leadership and get their guidance.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so we're going to develop a project management plan.
**Susan Daniels**: Interesting that they took the time in pmi after all this lies and all the documentation and all the books, you know that all the material in the book that is available, they actually.
**Susan Daniels**: articulated document, the project management plan it's sort of like no it's not okay to keep it all just walking around knowledge right.
**Susan Daniels**: Which is sort of the norm with non professional project managers, the ones that don't have the certification they're managing by what's in their head.
**Susan Daniels**: And if Lord forbid anything bad happened to that project manager, no one can step in behind them quickly and efficiently.
**Susan Daniels**: Where if you've done your due diligence documented what you've been guided to document then anyone at any time can step in and take over your project now that might make some people nervous.
**Susan Daniels**: don't be the only way, you can get promoted rapidly is to be.
**Susan Daniels**: Well, another way to say it is transferable Okay, so if you are the only one who knows this right, then you got to stay where you're at and do what you do, but if you can.
**Susan Daniels**: be someone that like well she's real good with her documentation he's real good with his documentation, I think we could probably just move so and so over this project and give this professional the higher profile more career catapulting project okay.
**Susan Daniels**: They can move you and accelerate you quicker if there's someone who can come in and fill your place, but if you only have it in your head walking around and you're not replaceable you're making yourself stuck where you're at.
**Susan Daniels**: I hope that makes sense to you is extremely important to document your project management plan okay.
**Susan Daniels**: And then assess incremental delivery options what that is trying to say is this Maybe you can only plan to a certain horizon line.
**Susan Daniels**: let's say let's go back to that analogy of building a super mall right.
**Susan Daniels**: And you can only really in detail, you have high level outlines and plans in your work breakdown structure, you know you're going to do all these different construction phases.
**Susan Daniels**: But in the first one, you only lock in once you can see, in that first horizon line your scope your schedule and your cost your quality okay.
**Susan Daniels**: that's what this is say have a master plan have the big picture laid out, but only lock in.
**Susan Daniels**: The Near term horizon line, and that is called using progressive elaboration planning, I will repeat it's an important term you'll see it in your glossary when you go to study your glossary progressive elaboration.
**Susan Daniels**: Well, to elaborate means to expand upon to you long game right to elaborate is to expand upon something.
**Susan Daniels**: So progressive means like over time so over time, as your project progresses, you can expand upon the details of your project, thus is called rolling wave planning or progressive elaboration.
**Susan Daniels**: interchangeable as far as I know, okay So yes, norm i'm, also known as rolling way planning, but you might see the term progressive elaboration now i've got a moment i'm going to share an inside project management professional joke with you.
**Susan Daniels**: So we're sitting around picture yourself sitting around at a pmi conference and people are telling war stories about their project.
**Susan Daniels**: And one gut person goes to another, you know i'm using progressive elaboration as my planning approach translation often means i'm making it up as I go.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, I got the big picture, but i'm making it up as I go so progressive elaboration is a professional term for doing just that.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so if your leadership goes well this deep this project plan doesn't seem very detailed you know for the violence, this is, I understand the requirements, I just haven't locked in the schedule and the.
**Susan Daniels**: The the budget until we're done with this increment Okay, then he and they'll go oh Okay, and you very you know bow up and go.
**Susan Daniels**: You do understand i'm using progressive elaboration as my planning approach is an incremental lifecycle okay well you're going to sound very professional like you know your stuff and you're not going to get challenged.
**Susan Daniels**: i've done it a couple of times.
**Susan Daniels**: So now we're talking about i'm changing subject guys so i'm.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay i'm so i'm changing subjects to managing change so presume that we have we're fast forward, we have done all the heavy lifting right to create our scope schedule cost quality we've got all the subsidiary plans and drafting.
**Susan Daniels**: Excuse me.
**Susan Daniels**: And now, what happens if things change in your environment right now i'm still just talking about traditional predictive waterfall Okay, this is the methodology i'm in.
**Susan Daniels**: And we'll talk about how you do change management and agile that's not what i'm talking about want to be clear, this applies to traditional.
**Susan Daniels**: waterfall and plan based.
**Susan Daniels**: So managing change.
**Susan Daniels**: So there's really two types of change that can happen in your project.
**Susan Daniels**: And there are two approaches that we use, so this is a rich slide I would put a tag on it, or I would store it Okay, so that you know, to come back to this one, specifically, some people use little flags whatever you want to do sticky flax.
Okay.
**Susan Daniels**: let's go back to the iron triangle right what you hang your reputation you've locked in all of the requirements right it's been approved we're not doing anything more than this.
**Susan Daniels**: Then, if that is required and we're not doing anything less than what is required and you've got your requirements, improved through a particular document does anybody remember what document we sent to leadership.
**Susan Daniels**: To get our requirements approved.
**Susan Daniels**: It tied everything to a specific business justification okay to a specific objective of our project.
**Susan Daniels**: Good morning we've got some people on top of things okay.
hey.
**Susan Daniels**: I was talking specifically about.
**Susan Daniels**: The right answer i'll keep looking at the answers here, but what I was looking for the to send up to senior leadership to lock in your scope okay what's required is your requirements traceability matrix okay that's what locked it in.
**Susan Daniels**: Now, whenever any of those you're going to have new requirements Okay, a new requirements that that need money or time to execute it goes through formal change management okay.
**Susan Daniels**: If it's only talking about a specification okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Other requirement, then it's an update to your configuration management plan.
**Susan Daniels**: So, in your notes, I want you to put with the word configuration Okay, I want you to put equals specification equals detail.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, your configuration management system Okay, is going to keep track of all of the details, where your.
**Susan Daniels**: Your implementation plan and you're managing your your plant your management plan is going to have the requirements to let me give you an example that will help clarify this for you okay.
**Susan Daniels**: let's say that you're on a project, and one of the things that have to happen, one of the you know, one of the work streams that have to happen is updating and educating the customer service REPS right.
**Susan Daniels**: And so the customer service REPS work off of screens that's how they get their information that's how they you know communicate.
**Susan Daniels**: So you know you have to build certain screens, so you have a list of requirements of what screens customer service may need they might need product descriptions screens.
**Susan Daniels**: They might need Frequently Asked Questions screens right and you got what data fields go in each one of these screens is all part of your requirements.
**Susan Daniels**: But for each one of these screens, now that you know you have a requirement and what data fields go on that screen.
**Susan Daniels**: there's still details to be figured out.
**Susan Daniels**: So the details, such as how many alphanumeric characters will that data field have what font will that field half what font size what font color what location all of those specifications those details on how that screen is configured okay go into your configuration management system.
**Susan Daniels**: I hope that clarifies the difference between the requirement okay to have this Green and the different fields and the specifications of how it is configured okay.
**Susan Daniels**: So you now need to build two plans on how you're going to manage change at those two different levels.
**Susan Daniels**: Your anything that's going to require more time or money probably needs your sponsors approval right because you're talking about being late.
**Susan Daniels**: or or spending more so you're going to need a formal change control process put in place.
**Susan Daniels**: And who sits on it and how often does it meet and who's got a voice who's got to vote, what is the change request form look like, where is it found what's the link to that location, who facilitates getting it done.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, your project manager okay.
**Susan Daniels**: That whole how are we gonna manage change to the requirements of this project.
**Susan Daniels**: oftentimes your Organization has that process in place, but not always, and the smaller the organization you're in the less likely a formal change control process exists so whose job is it to build it.
**Susan Daniels**: You get one guess.
You.
**Susan Daniels**: You have to design your own projects formal change control process once you build it right.
**Susan Daniels**: It will save you lots of stress, so it may be some heavy lifting in the beginning, but it is worth all the effort to have it in place, because when people come at you to make changes they will okay.
**Susan Daniels**: You know what to do, and you know how to how to facilitate hey here's my formal change request form we have meetings every two weeks here's who sits on my change Control Board okay.
**Susan Daniels**: And once they realize who sits on your board, they still may or may not want to go forward right hey so designing it forward designing it in advance is a requirement as part of your master plans.
**Susan Daniels**: This configuration management plan your configuration management system okay really is little more than taking your.
**Susan Daniels**: Requirements traceability matrix remember that spreadsheet that we showed in the beginning, each requirement, how it was justified, who did it come from what work package did it tie to okay right so you've got the basis of all of your requirements already listed good place to start.
**Susan Daniels**: add more columns to that on who has authority over the specifications right now, you start adding specifications like what's the font size, the color the location that sort of thing, who has authority over that particular work packages.
**Susan Daniels**: specifications add a column for changes what you know what day was a change and another column for the justification okay now you've got your configuration management system kind of built okay.
**Susan Daniels**: what's the value of a configuration management system and having your plan in place where is it stored right how, how do you access it here's where the value is.
**Susan Daniels**: I see your question about who comprises a change Control Board we'll talk about that more in governance, but the short answer is.
**Susan Daniels**: Your sponsors, for one, and sometimes the end recipient of the change sometimes the company pays for things that other people didn't really ask for, but it's being driven by.
**Susan Daniels**: By strategy at the highest level, so it would be the people who are paying for it and sometimes the person on the end.
**Susan Daniels**: oftentimes in person receiving is the one that paid for it, but not always, but those are your key players, for your change Control Board back to configuration management plan.
**Susan Daniels**: picture, if you will you're trying to get your coffee in the morning, and you know you haven't even started today.
**Susan Daniels**: And around the corner comms this person all bowed up and they are hoc and they are there to tell you they are not happy that they have changed something in your project.
**Susan Daniels**: Say one of these screens right they changed the alphanumeric length of a.
**Susan Daniels**: Data field, and it now guys causing ripple effects through the screens and their stuff no longer fits on that screen and Wah Wah Wah Wah Wah they're all mad and hot now personally i've got bigger things that i'm worried about and there's much more.
**Susan Daniels**: influencing i'm doing than worried about the alphanumeric length of a data field, so I basically don't know who changed it or why, as my every day walking around knowledge, so I will respond to this person something like well clearly you feel strongly about this have a SIP of coffee.
**Susan Daniels**: Let me check my configuration management system see who changed it and what the justifications are i'll send you that information.
**Susan Daniels**: As soon as I get out of my nine o'clock meeting okay.
**Susan Daniels**: Now, did you take the ball to fix that problem, no but did you tell them that you were going to give them the information they needed to be able to figure out who changed it and why, which is what they wanted to know right when they.
**Susan Daniels**: Confronted you you've now given them a satisfactory answer on what's going to where to go next.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so this configuration management system saves you from really having to deal with the infinite details involved in your project.
**Susan Daniels**: you've delegated that work package authority to change information on that work package to one person and apparently it wasn't the person who's mad Okay, but now you know you know who she needs to go talk to.
**Susan Daniels**: If that problems circles again, you may need to get involved and conflict management, but at the moment that matter has now be handled move on to the next and we're making sense here there's a lot of value in having this system.
**Susan Daniels**: On.
**Susan Daniels**: let's see i'm going to take a moment to read here before I jump into the next slide.
**Susan Daniels**: What is the best practice when staff sections are resistant to change all change management is a whole theory and methods approach I can't get into.
**Susan Daniels**: How to handle change management at this point, as far as the personnel aspect of it we're still just talking um.
**Susan Daniels**: The more tactical aspects of your project good question I wish I could answer it right now but that's not where we are in the lecture.
**Susan Daniels**: Susan is the change management plan developed per project or is that determined by the organization and then project has to adhere to that good question thanks Paul.
**Susan Daniels**: kind of gets back to the organization you're working with oftentimes there is in sophisticated companies that have something called a project management office a P m O is the acronym that's another one, you need to know P m o
**Susan Daniels**: project management Office, this is where organizations have all of the project management capabilities are housed in one place we'll get into organizational structures for project management.
**Susan Daniels**: much later like towards the last morning of this boot camp, but if your Organization has a P mo then they've got a change management process standardized and formalized.
**Susan Daniels**: If you join an organization that does not have a PM our odds are you have to build it Okay, but once you design it.
**Susan Daniels**: All you change out is who are the decision makers you keep the same form, you could probably keep the same cadence of meetings.
**Susan Daniels**: You probably keep the same you know i'm process design you just change out who's sitting in the chairs, making the decision I hope that's helpful so design at once, and then just kind of Edit it as you need to.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, yes i'll be glad to do this in your you take your requirements trace of the question was repeat the columns you would add to your resource traceability matrix to come up with a configuration management system.
**Susan Daniels**: Who is accountable for this word package, which is already you know, one of those columns who's accountable.
**Susan Daniels**: Is this a person that has the authority often always it is okay, who has the authority to change the specifications usually the person who's accountable.
**Susan Daniels**: And then, when was it changed when and why, like the justification of why.
**Susan Daniels**: And you might want to call them of what specifically was changed right what's this ethically.
**Susan Daniels**: So I hope that was helpful.
**Susan Daniels**: So i'm going to say we're done understanding the difference between these very high, you know one relative to your scope for your change management plan and the configuration management plan is about the details.
**Susan Daniels**: I like this slide this slide basically says that we have what needs to be taken into consideration when you're doing.
**Susan Daniels**: i'm writing a change management plan, if you can answer these questions, then you probably have a pretty solid plan and chain in place, so let me elaborate just a little bit more on it um before we we go to break.
**Susan Daniels**: So what exactly constitutes to change it has like we said, it has to be a new requirement that it's going to take time or resources or both i'm looking over here at my notes guys um.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, the next one is, of course, you have to figure out what the impact is right, what is the ripple effect through your project.
**Susan Daniels**: And you ask them to try to tell you what they think the impact is and then you have to fill it out the rest of the way Okay, because you've got the bigger picture you're the integrator.
**Susan Daniels**: um when a change request is approved okay what project documents will record the next steps that's simply says what documents in that will be.
**Susan Daniels**: open for change the schedule your budget your quality plan it may impact your procurement plan your listing what potential plans may be impacted and what you do is you sort of list your.
**Susan Daniels**: Your subsidiary plans and then you check off which ones are actually impacted and then you have a space beside it saying what it is the change would would be.
**Susan Daniels**: How do you monitor those actions to current confirm completion and quality, this is getting back into your monitoring and controlling accountability.
**Susan Daniels**: What report needs to be updated right what what question needs to be added, how are we going to make sure that this new requirement is actually going to be executed to the quality expectations so that's going to be filled out as well.
**Susan Daniels**: I often get asked are there examples of change management plans that exist out there and the short answer is yes, you just need to look for some starter ideas that's the beautiful thing about the pmi standards and project management COM, they are great places to get templates.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay we're closing in on close to the top of the hour.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay um.
**Susan Daniels**: This is i'm switching now i'm switching from the traditional predictive waterfall methodology and i'm switching to how has changed manage or complexity managed in the agile environment right dynamic.
**Susan Daniels**: environment which you're trying to be highly adaptive where change is expected change and feedback, is welcome.
**Susan Daniels**: Where we're only working in short iterations like sprint's okay 234 weeks at a time, so we are constantly looking for feedback to adapt.
**Susan Daniels**: different mindset right going from plan your work, work, your plan control for variances to we're going to give you something to react to get your reaction and then adapt from there that's more agile.
**Susan Daniels**: There you will see three bolted terms on this slide.
**Susan Daniels**: You should recognize and be able to recall and align those three terms with agile methodology okay.
**Susan Daniels**: We are going to cover scrum right on Friday we're going to go deep on with scrum is because it's a stroke it's an a long standing highly popular agile method okay.
**Susan Daniels**: But scrum of scrums is simply saying some projects require multiple teams to work simultaneously and how do you keep track of and manage multiple features being developed at the same time by different.
**Susan Daniels**: Development teams, so you have a scrum master for each team, but then you have your scrum masters meet together and that's called a scrum of scrums okay it's just a coordination method.
**Susan Daniels**: Your scaled agile framework Okay, is an enterprise wide way of managing things in an adaptive environment, you are not expected to understand how to do scale.
**Susan Daniels**: you're not expected to know how to do scrum of scrums you're expected to understand that these are scrum methodologies for managing complex projects on projects.
**Susan Daniels**: I deliberately skipped over discipline to agile.
**Susan Daniels**: You are expected to understand that discipline agile takes into all different kinds of agile tools and techniques, including scrum of scrums including scale.
**Susan Daniels**: Discipline agile is think of an umbrella in your notes writing umbrella Okay, like a big arch and that would be disciplined agile.
**Susan Daniels**: which takes all of this, it takes in combat it takes an all the different tools and techniques under that arch an example would be scrum of scrums is scale I hope that's helpful for your notes, but you need to know the whole thing is an agile mystic way of managing complex projects.
**Susan Daniels**: Okay, so we've spent an hour really just on writing your project management plan.
**Susan Daniels**: And the components of it and then how to manage change relevant to it when we come back we're going to talk about procurement.
**Susan Daniels**: Please enjoy your time we're going to take our 15 minutes like we usually do okay get it refresh your cup of coffee and I will see you in 15 minutes.